Bettie page was arguably the most popular
supermodel of the 20th century and she
would go down in history
as the queen of pet up.
Even if you haven't heard of her yet.
Once you know who she is,
you will begin to see her influence
practically everywhere you go.
If you live in the United States images
and inspired by her still show up in
music, videos and movies and
pop culture to this very day,
even if you recognize her face. Very few
people know the story of her real life.
This woman never used her circumstances
as an excuse for failure and then the
amount of grit she needed to overcome
obstacles to achieve her dreams is
absolutely astounding.
This is the inspirational,
true story of Betty Page.
Betty Mae. Paige was born on
April the 22nd 1923 in Nashville,
Tennessee.
She was the second of six children and
the oldest daughter of royal and a page.
Her father was an auto mechanic,
but he was also an alcoholic and
he had trouble holding down a job.
My mother was a housewife and those
six kids kept to extremely busy.
During the Great Depression,
Ryan moved the family around from place
to place because he could never keep a
job. He was inflicting all forms of abuse
on his wife and daughters and he often
cheated on Admin as well.
When Betsy was 10 years old,
her mother finally found the
strength to get a divorce.
Adding the page now had to work full
time even though a few of our kids were
still just toddlers and babies.
Since she did not have much education,
she could only find very low paying jobs.
As the oldest daughter,
all of the usual domestic
responsibility fell on Betty.
She was still only 10 that became the
surrogate mother to a younger siblings by
cooking, cleaning, and babysitting.
She did all of this cheerfully and
always had a smile on our face. Indeed,
their house became very popular because
after school that neighborhood kids
could come over to the house and play
together without any adult supervision.
That's a loved watching movies and they
were her escape from her harsh reality.
They inspired her to sing and dance.
In the back yard on a makeshift stage
that the kids made out of discarded scraps
of wood. Since this was
during the Great Depression,
the kids did not have many
toys to play with this.
They were entertained by
Betty's imagination as in
as she had an audience who
will eagerly await to
see what she did next.
She was always pushing the envelope and
thinking about our next performance,
but those dreams they would come to a
screeching halt. Even with Betty's helped.
Six children was faulty.
Much responsibility for
add nuts and manage alone.
Even those you worked full time.
The amount of money she
made was simply not enough.
Ryan was not sending her any form of
child support and they simply never heard
from him again.
It got so bad that hadn't have to choose
between starvation and giving up some
of our children to an orphanage as he,
until youngest sister were together in
an old girls' home and she encouraged to
assist the,
to pretends that they were characters
in a movie like playing pretend to,
to help Toronto and Ptosis to stay
strong and resilient through this rather
traumatic experience.
After a few years,
Betty's mother had saved up enough
money and was able to get custody of her
children again.
That's,
he was a few years old now and she had
grown into a beautiful young woman, Edna.
No was concerned.
The Betty might make the same mistake she
did and give up her future by marrying
the first guy who came along.
So she made a rule that Betty was not
allowed to have a boyfriends but ours,
like most teenagers, Betty rebelled
in high school. She fell a Billy Neal,
the all star quarterback
from the rival high school.
He was everything you would imagine of
the stereotypical cool kid back then he
wore leather jackets. He rode a motorcycle
to school and probably skipped class,
just smoke cigarettes.
But that's just speculation
that he fell in love with Billy.
But the years spends in the orphanage,
they were more than enough for her to
know that she never wanted to depend on a
man for her financial security
as their mother had done.
She wanted to get a college education
so that she could always support herself
if she needed to.
Keep in mind now that in 1940 over 50%
of the u s population dropped out of
school after the eighth grade,
very few women went on to get a high
school diploma mirror and even fewer went
on to attempt to college degree.
If they did.
They usually came from well to
do families in the upper class,
but Betty wasn't going to let
family history stopper afterschool,
but he joins the debate team and
school theatrical productions.
She studied extremely hard and
graduated second in our class.
This allowed her to win a full academic
scholarship to Peabody's teacher's
college. This was also the moment
that she got married to Billy meal,
even though she's still dreamed
of being a Hollywood starlet.
Billy wanted them to have a
life together in Nashville.
She loved him so much that she didn't
want to break up with him just to pursue
her dream.
The next best thing was to
become a teacher since she
would be able to do public
speaking and share her
knowledge with younger kids.
So after getting a bachelor's degree
that he started teaching at her old high
school,
have all my principal and teachers
remembered how she excelled in academics
because she was still in our early
twenties and nos all that far off from the
age of our students.
She was so beautiful that she became a
target of harassment by the young boys.
The male students thought that
with our perfect hourglass curves,
she was simply too distracting
to be their teacher.
No matter how intelligent
she was on the inside,
hardly anyone could see past what she
looked like on the outside of our know and
can take a female teacher seriously unless
she looks like professor McGonagall.
Her husband's Billy Neal joins the army
and they stationed him at a military
base in San Francisco before
sending them overseas as his wife,
Betty quit her job as a teacher and
was very excited about the move to
California.
She took this opportunity to switch
career paths and got a new job as a
secretary.
One of the men who visited her office
said that she was pretty enough to be in
the movies and he offered to help her
get an audition in Los Angeles. Betty,
it was excited hoping that this would
be the big break that would make her the
movie star that should always dreamed
of being that he showed up for a screen
test by 20th century Fox,
but she hated the experience.
She was poked and prodded by the makeup,
hair and costume to the point where
she didn't even recognize herself.
When she looked in the mirror, they
told her that if she wanted to make it,
she would have to change a
lot of things about herself,
like going blonde and doing
a makeup in a different way.
The man who helped her get the screen
test made a move on how promising her fame
and fortune in exchange
for sleeping with him,
but to Betsy turned down his advances.
The men Freston to Ruben had reputation
and promised that he would make sure
that no one ever hot her in Hollywood.
Still,
she chose to stay faithful to her husband
and she walked away. But Betty Paige,
she wasn't alone today.
We know that the likes of Harvey Weinstein
and Bill Cosby made it a habit of
preying on young actresses and that
this was happening to women for decades
before as well. Even though she had
been completely faithful to Billy,
he was actually angry to come home and
find out that she was pursuing our acts
in Korea while he was gone.
He wanted it to be satisfied with just
being a housewife and Dee wanted to move
back to Tennessee.
She realized that their ambitions in life,
they were completely different and they
were just simply not compatible any
longer and with that they
decided to get a divorce.
In 1947 a 24 years old,
Bessie moved to New York City and began
auditioning for plays and movies and
commercials.
Unfortunately,
she ran into the same problems that
she had in Los Angeles and they didn't
charge once.
It more than just a talent say in
exchange for her work and she refused to
change a moral compass for three years.
She works as a secretary and
Manhattan as the is slipped by.
She was now considered to be too old
to start a career in show business.
She had given up everything in order to
be an actress and soon enough it would
be too late.
One day,
Betty was walking along the beach on Coney
island's when she noticed a man doing
pushups on the beach. This was a
police officer named Jerry tips.
He said that he was a professional
photographer on the side and asked if she
would be interested in being
paid to be a model fam.
After talking to him for a while longer,
she decided to say yes when Tibbs last,
how old she was.
She pretended to be in her early twenties
even though by now she was already a
27 year old divorcee.
Nowadays,
this line about being a photographer
who is inviting a young woman into his
basement for pictures is
used by a surprisingly large
number of serial killers
and of course perverts,
but thankfully for her,
the photography sessions went just
as Tibbs said they would just,
and she was paid handsomely for her time.
Many of her photos began showing up
and girly magazines around Harlem.
Given minds that this was off to world
war two were photos of pinup girls has
become incredibly popular.
A lot of young women at wants it to do
their part to help the troops and even
after the war posing provocative leaf,
a pinup at became a
goal of aspiring models.
So Betty Paige was excited to be part
of this and she had had such a good
experience with Jerry Tibbs.
This,
he invited dad to become
a part of a camera club.
In the 1950s Camera Club was where a
studio would bring in a group of models.
Both amateur and professional
photographers would pay
a fee to come and take
pictures of beautiful women.
Sometimes men would show up with a
camera that was mts simply because they
wanted an excuse to all beautiful women
wearing lingerie up close and personal.
But Betty Page wasn't just
good at modeling. She was
a genius. She needed very,
this'll direction from the photographers
and knew how to strike a pose.
Her face was always cheerful,
looking friendly and approachable.
There was something about her that made
men feel that she was the girl next door.
Many of the camera men,
it's often stop taking pictures of the
other girls and spend more time on her
because she was just that good at a job.
Soon enough,
Betty Paige was raking in money and she
made far more than she ever had as a
secretary. She saw this as a stepping
stone to finally make it into the movies.
Now today,
it's totally normal for the likes of
Victoria secret angels to be on a strict
diet and exercise regimen every single
day to keep themselves fit, but,
but back then,
models usually showed up to have photos
taken of their natural body. Bettie page,
though she didn't rely on a
natural beauty to get the job done.
She works out every day,
watch their diet,
and even so new costumes that
would look good on camera.
She treated it all very
much like a business and
everything she did during heck
area was the new standard for what models
would be expected to do in the future.
She began receiving requests to do
photo shoots all over New York City,
and eventually she became a million app.
Whenever it tastes changed,
photography is expected Bettie page to
do things that were more and more risk a,
she would agree to do it despite any
previous hesitations that she had in the
past. She knew that times were changing
and if she wanted to keep her career in
business going, she would have
to begin posing in the nude.
If you think of willingness to pose nude
sounds sort of contradictory when you
consider the fact that she refused
to sleep with anyone to get the job.
She had this to say being in the nude
isn't a disgrace unless you're being
promiscuous about is often roll.
When God created Adam and Eve,
they were stark naked and in the gods
into these and God was probably naked as a
Jay bird too.
So if she continued to pose naked so
long as she thought that it was at least
tasteful,
one day the camera club decided to find
a secluded area in upstate New York to
have a nude photo shoot outside where
the models were frolicking in the grass
and it shouldn't be a surprise to you
that the police showed up and arrested.
The women and the photographers.
They challenged the men with disturbing
the peace and the women with indecent
exposure that he actually yelled at the
police officers saying that she refused
to accept that charge because
she was not an indecent person.
She demanded to have the same challenge
as the men and they finally gave in and
changing it to disturbing
the peace despite having to
serve time in jail for her
nude photos. She still continued
to do these photo shoots anyway.
During the peak of our popularity.
Bettie page became Ms January in 1955
in playboy magazine who half no one said
that he slept with 11 out of 12 of the
cover models of each playboy issue in
Betty Page would have been
not one exception who didn't
have to sleep with him
in exchange for being published.
They actually purchased a nude photos
from a female photographer and fellow
model named Bunny Yeager
have not respected page
immensely saying that she was a
remarkable lady and iconic figure in pop
culture who influenced sexuality tastes
in fashion. Someone who had a
tremendous impact on our society.
When the issue of playboy came out,
we can only imagine how her former
high school students, Mr Fellows,
when they opened up the
pages of playboy ends,
figured out that the teacher they once
had a crush on has now done a full spread
of nudes in glossy prints. For some,
that was probably a dream come true.
Modeling was paying the bills,
but Betty Page still wanted to move in
the direction of being in the movies.
Sibling business partners,
Paula and Irving core ran the movie
star new store where they sold beauty
photography of pinup models.
They also film short clips of Betty
dancing in lingerie and sold them to
customers.
She eventually started in two movies
called Stripper Rama and varieties after
work. Betty was taking acting classes
and auditioning for plays on Broadway,
but without much luck.
In 1955 percenters are named as of Alpha,
created a subcommittee that was cracking
down on comic books, pornography,
and it's basically anything else
that could be considered sinful.
The FBI detained Betty
Page and interrogated her,
asking if Irving and Paula claw web
shooting pornographic movies at the movie
star new store.
Betty pretested saying that the women
were never fully nude in these movies and
there were never any men in them either.
Betty's boss seven claw was taken the
course before the Senate subcommittee,
even though he was found not guilty.
The mere suggestion that she was starring
in porn ruined about his reputation,
her name, it was printed in
newspapers all over New York City.
Bettie page became the target of slut
shaming and men were yelling at her in the
streets. A store could began to center
letters threatening to kill her.
Since she had gotten to know
the FBI agents in New York City,
she contacted them right away.
They believe that the person who send
the letters was a known serial killer.
They set up a plan where they used
Betty is bait to catch the murder.
Rand's only jumped in at
the last minute to save her.
It turns out that the stalker
was only a 16 year old boy,
but all of this took a serious toll on
Betty's mental health and it was all
downhill from that.
In 1957 the savings have to shut down
the movie star new store and Betty Paige
was out of a job.
She decided to stop working as a model
and give up her dream of becoming an
actress. She moved to Florida and
became a born again Christian.
The church made her feel like she was
a sinner and that she needed to repent.
While in Florida.
She began to attend Bible College and
trying to become a Christian missionary
overseas. In the 1960s however, only
found out that she was a divorcee.
They reject it to us saying that she was
to indecent is to represent the church.
She began taking graduate courses to Anna
Masters degree in the hopes that maybe
she grew back to being a teacher,
but our reputation.
It followed her there too and
she dropped out. All along,
her mental state continued to decline
and by the 1970s she was beginning to
suffer from schizophrenia.
She had a nervous breakdown and
ended up in a mental hospital.
After receiving psychiatric treatment
for several years, she was released.
During that time,
she had to be essentially d programs
because the church should brainwashed her
into hating herself and all of our
accomplishments. As time went on,
there was a revival in
interest of a Betty Page.
She had been one of the most
photographed models of the 20th century,
and when she retired, she
seemingly disappeared. Explanation.
People wanted to know what had
happened to her and the mystery.
It only added to the
excitement for 40 years.
No one had heard anything about
life. After modeling. In 1998,
Playboy magazine tracked her down and
asked for an interview. They asked, uh,
if she ever felt ashamed of
her work while she was doing,
or if those feelings of guilt came
after she started receiving criticism.
She said, I never thought it
was shameful. I felt normal.
It's just that it was much better than
pounding a typewriter eight hours a day,
which gets monotonous,
or the rest of her life fans and Betty
Page letters telling her how much they
loved and appreciated our bravery for
paving the way for so many other women.
And she finally got the recognition
and love that she deserved.
She died of a heart attack in 2008 at
85 years old. At the time of her death,
she had a net worth of $20 million
even though it was considered to
be very scandalous at the time.
That sort of modeling Betty Paige did
is on par with Victoria secrets and the
Calvin Klein ads of today near New Jersey
has become such a big part of American
culture that some young women even but
similar photos of themselves on Instagram
without a second thought today,
we'd barely baton eyelid.
That those images of Betty Page
that were deemed to be so sinful and
inappropriate,
one thing is for certain though without
are things wouldn't be the same.
Bettie page is iconic.
Look also became the inspiration for
a number of fictional characters,
including Jenny Blake from a comic
book called the rocket [inaudible].
She also inspired the looks of
celebrities like Katy Perry, Madonna,
and the modern day burlesque dancer,
Dita von Teese. In modern times,
most men have moved on to
having crushes on other females.
Celebrities and the photos of Betty
Page may not seem like anything special
today. She is actually now more popular
with women, especially feminists.
She was strong, smart, independent,
and never backed down on
what she believed was right.
Even if it took her years
of heartache and struggle,
she was able to make it in the
modeling industry on her own terms.
Even after a death or estate continues
to make tons of money in 2017 oh then
Betty Page merchandise
sold for $7 million.
Her memory will continue to live on as
one of the most iconic women in all of
history. So I already have you found
that video. Interesting. If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up below.
Don't forget to subscribe brand new videos
just like this every day of the week
if you're looking at something
else to watch right now,
but I've got another channel.
It's called top tens we do
interesting top 10 lists.
You can find that link to below as well
as on the screen now and as always,
thank you for watching.